my last company was a company that
created technology for measuring
viewership and cable television systems
and we used to collect data from lanes
in millions of homes and but when you
start looking at the data was shocking
but majority of the people watch seven
or eight channels and half of them
happen to be broadcast television
channels that are free to air prices
keep escalating technology doesn't keep
pace people are consuming more content
online people are shaving the cord
cutting the cord that expressing their
interest in moving away from the
traditional model how close is the
company today to the one that you first
envisioned it startups out a strange
behavior I did you start something and
then you test it in you pivot and then
you pivot again and then you have a
couple of mishaps and CEOs get fired
it's a pretty common story this is the
first time that I have observed what I
will call a clockwork like execution
this is exactly what we set out to do in
fact we knew what
wanted it in so well that we move
extremely fast and this was to the teeth
and what about a legal side you must
have anticipated maybe some legal
hurdles did you anticipate this kind of
legal fight the things that I didn't
anticipate were going to happen like the
direct impact Association of the area
with sort of future of computing cloud a
variety of these things that were if I
take in the moment to step back and say
wow but I you know you never do and so I
think a lot of those things the
controversy be anticipated but again the
scope and scale of what is transpiring
was a surprise outside of courtrooms
broadcasters continue to speak about
what their options are in terms of where
they can take their channels we can move
our broadcast network to cable we can
take our broadcast network to the
Internet what do you say to that look
they've had an agenda to go to cable for
a very long time area has got nothing to
do with it right but then you take a
step back and you say 60 million people
you
some way shape or form this is nav stat
right so are they capable of
disenfranchised that large a number of
people I don't think I think that's a
that's a very difficult issue to be
clear if you were not to be successful
at the Supreme Court level is there a
plan B for area no there's no plan I
think we believe in our merit
and not just believe in the merit we do
think it's the right thing its progress
is important the mission of this company
was to try to create an open platform
try to wedge the system open a little
bit and if we don't succeed in that
despite our best efforts and good law on
our side and the merits of our case and
be a tragedy but it is what it is have
you ever thought about maybe selling the
company say hey we started to grow
pretty quickly let somebody else worry
about these legal headaches I'm a
open-minded businessman at the end of
the day and an engineer so I always look
at what is the best way to get your idea
out in front of as many people as you
possibly can so I always look at
partnerships or any of those things
along with that particular lens thus far
we felt us driving the bus and
innovating and pushing the boundaries is
the best approach now if that context
changes in the future will entertain
anything at all but the lens that we
apply is what is the best way best
experience best way possible to get in
front of it
we closed weekend